this is Siobhan tamp like well and I'm
sure you all know that it's been a
season of disastrous events and we
wanted to make sure that you knew that
we have created and updated some of our
information guides to keep you up to
date with the Hurricanes Maria
Irma and Harvey so we created a
hurricanes of 2017 page we hope that we
don't have to update it any more this
year but we do have a page and Jen if
you can put the URL to that in the chat
box that would be great and we also
updated our fires and wildfires page the
Hurricanes of 2017 page is already
syndicated in our store and you can take
the code from that page and add it to
your website and it will automatically
update every time we update it and you
can add local content at the top of that
page so if you're interested in learning
more about content syndication you can
send one of us an email and let us know
if you're having problems the fires in
wildfires page will be ready it's it's
in the process of being syndicated so
either later today or tomorrow morning
that page the information on the
syndication will be on the websites a
couple of other things we are
redesigning our website and this after
lit database for great literature will
be it's probably still a couple of
months away but just a heads up to let
you know that that's coming there's been
an update to the wiser apps for the iOS
platform only the changes will be coming
to Android soon but it's because we
thought it was great to talk about this
today since it's on mapping arm there
the update
iOS platform uses now the compass
feature on your iPhone so for protective
distance mapping you can either manually
set where the wind is coming from which
we've already had but now you can also
point the top of your device into the
wind and then the animation on the
device shows where the wind is coming
from the compass automatically will
adjust and then you hit set the wind
direction so it helps and helps you get
the wind direction a little bit more
specific so this is kind of an exciting
change and even though we're still in
October and about to start our October
call we did want to make sure you knew
that November 6 through the 12 is
humanitarian evidence week and our
November call will be in honor of that
week of beyond improving the
availability availability of reliable
health information and it's going to
include a presentation on our disaster
lips the scope of it and how we select
for it but also will include a
presentation on the platform health care
information for all HIPAA which promotes
communication among state stakeholders
to realize a vision of a world where
every person will have access to health
care information that they need to
protect their own health and the health
of others all right so I'm going to go
ahead Kurt are you back or should I
start Jerry yes I'm back and also we're
gonna save questions till the end so
please use the chat box to enter your
questions and then Genpact iam just
gonna keep track of them and we'll let
Kurt and John know what your questions
are so thanks now I'll be quiet
hey so good afternoon this is John Scott
my background my organization is Center
for Public Service Communications and my
background is natural hazards disaster
risk reduction I'm a project
manager and co-founder of the community
health maps initiative with my partner
Kirk manky who's on the line who is GIS
expert I'm located in Maryland and Kirk
is in Albuquerque and of course the
project resides at national library
medicine so if the project resides
within the outreach and special
populations branch of the division of
specialized information services at NLM
you're familiar with them probably
through your association with Dimmick
which is one of the partners in the
division next slide so the community
health map initiative is the the mission
of our program is to empower community
organizations with a focus on vulnerable
populations though not exclusively and
those who need effective scalable
mapping tools to be able to understand
and visualize there in this case there
are health risks and for those who lack
resources what has been the historical
types of GIS software and platforms that
are expensive to purchase and subscribe
to and and train and I usually take a
minute to identify a little soapbox
issue that we have I think when you go
through this slide presentation you'll
see an immediate value perhaps to many
of your programs of the kind of mapping
approach that we've taken what we want
to call your attention to is what we see
is the particulars of our approach and
that is that historically mapping and
other health information technologies
with respect to vulnerable communities
mapping tends to have been done to the
or on behalf of them historically
whereas now with the approach that we've
taken and with open-source tools mapping
can be done with communities and by
communities on that level so that there
is a much more active potential for much
more active engagement with the
community and the communities themselves
are able to better understand their risk
visualize it and use that information to
advocate for for services that might be
designed to reduce the risk next slide
so just very briefly here because this
is an NLM funded initiative its
relevance to the NLM mission we think is
obvious but NLM seeks to collect and
maintain and make available the world's
biomedical information and one way to
understand information better as we've
come to learn is to be able to visualize
it curt in some of his slides we'll make
that more clear visually and so we find
ourselves very comfortably within NLM's
family and the partnership has been a
good one next now I'll turn it over to
Kirk all right afternoon everyone so I
wanted to just start out by just going
through a little bit of what you can do
with GIS and so what you're looking at
here is a table of information that is
neighborhoods in Baltimore City with
socio-economic data and diabetes rates
and if you're really familiar with it
you can probably you know glean some
trends by looking at that but I think
most people would see that it's much
more intuitive to put that data on to a
map so you're looking now at Baltimore
City neighborhoods colored by the
diabetes rate and then you're seeing
food deserts as black outlines and
dialysis centers as red stars and you
start to get a picture of what's going
on with
diabetes in the city and it's been
estimated that you know somewhere sixty
to eighty percent of all data has some
kind of geographic component to it and
by Geographic component I just mean
something that could be mapped like the
state or an address or the county or the
block group or actual coordinates that
would allow you to put that data onto a
map and once the data is on a map then
you can start answering spatial
questions of your data so and putting
the data into context and doing things
like measuring how far things are from
one another so especially thinking about
the issue of access to care for example
and then you can start doing even more
powerful things so you can do small and
even large spatial analyses so here the
red line is where a tornado touched down
and if you know that the tornado did
damage in a mile of where it touched
down you can do what's called buffer
that storm track and see where that
tornado would have done damage and then
identify the yellow parcels that might
have been affected so this is a you know
very simple analysis somebody can do in
a few seconds but it's something you can
only do if you have the actual spatial
data on a map so what we've developed as
community health maps is essentially a
workflow using existing low-cost and
open-source tools and it basically has
three components the first we'll go
through is mapping community data with
smartphones and tablets and I'll start
with that so we are recommending that
people would now use smartphones and
tablets and one reason for that is that
their intuitive and everyone is
comfortable with them and they're
getting more ubiquitous you know if we
were doing the same initiative five or
ten years ago we probably would have
been recommending necessarily that
people use these big expensive yellow
GPS receivers which are not intuitive
and
you know are expensive five to seven
thousand dollars each and so now we can
use smartphones and tablets to do a lot
of the data collection we might have
done with those and I always you know
like to quickly mentioned that accuracy
can be an issue in this effort so
smartphones and tablets use a hybrid
positioning technology there is a GPS
chip on smartphones and the GPS chip
will get you within about five to eight
meters
there's also it'll also locate you by a
wireless signal if you're connected to a
Wi-Fi network and it'll also get you
positioned by pinging off of cell phone
towers and if all three of these
technologies are available at the same
time the phone will try to use all three
in concert to give you even better
accuracy at your position so what we've
been showing people how to use for field
data collection is this tool called
fulcrum the website is there on the
slide and this is basically a tool that
lets you develop a custom questionnaire
or data collection form and you can
develop you're seeing a little animated
gif here that shows how it works when
you're developing a form and you can
pretty much set it up to collect you
know collect any kind of data and it's
available for Android and Apple so that
makes it nice and this is actually the
most expensive piece of what we have
people use it has a 30-day trial period
which we usually have people working
with at our workshops
after that 30 day trial period it's $18
a month for the least expensive
subscription rate but even for a an
organization $18 a month is usually
pretty bearable the next part of the
workflow is bringing your data onto the
desktop or your laptop and doing some
kind of analysis or making a map so you
may need to combine what was collected
in the community with some census data
or other databases that
the organization already has and for
this piece we've been showing people how
to use this open source GIS software
called QGIS and GIS is geographic
information systems so it's software
that lets you manipulate spatial data
create a map do an analysis and Q just
is a really powerful easy-to-use tool it
has kind of all all the capabilities you
need in a standard desktop GIS the third
leg of the workflow is web mapping and
so often these days it's really nice to
be able to put a final map onto your web
page as an interactive map by
interactive you can kind of think of a
Google map where you can zoom in zoom
out even turn layers off and on so this
will be kind of a date a final data
dissemination piece so we were looking
for something that would be very
intuitive because we don't expect our
audience to be programmers and so we've
come across this tool called cardo and
this is a tool that offers a free
account that doesn't timeout so you can
use the free account for quite a few
purposes and you upload your data into
your account that goes into your cloud
account there and then it has tools for
visualizing that data and then sharing
or publishing the map so here you're
seeing that same map of Baltimore City
and the diabetes rates built in Cardo
and so you can see when you're online
you can zoom and pan around and turn
layers off and on and you can click on
things and pop-ups will appear and this
is all configurable and we can usually
show people how to do a basic map like
this in 3040 minutes it's pretty
straightforward and intuitive so that's
the the community health maps workflow
and what we're going to do next is just
go through a few case studies because
we've been all over the country in
recent years conducting workshops with
different organizations
and I think we're gonna skip the first
one just in the interest of time and
start with this case study in Seattle
Washington with the urban Indian Health
Institute so they were interested in the
issue of noise pollution and how it
relates to chronic health effects and so
this is typically what we do we went in
and did a one-day in-person training and
we usually use this train-the-trainer
model where we are hoping to train kind
of community leaders that can then train
other people in the community to do this
mapping and so they wanted to serve a
Native American neighborhoods in Seattle
and measure noise pollution and so one
of the cool things about smart phones is
that there's an app for that
right so they found an app that would
measure decibels with the microphone on
the phone or tablet and they tested a
variety of apps this was the the best
one and they came up with a protocol for
sampling that noise and different points
during the day and different times
during the week so they got a good
average sample and this is the very
first map that they produced from the
first weekend's data collection the
darker the point the louder the decibel
reading was at that location and then
they started to bring in some per capita
income information so this is a map
produced in QGIS and we often call this
a hypothesis generating tool so they can
collect the data and bring in this per
capita income and just see if they're
starting to find any trends that might
require more investigation another
project that came out of Seattle was
working with the School of Public Health
at the University of Washington they
have a capstone course program there
that the students do on the final
semester where they spend the semester
doing a project of their own design and
so John and I went up there and and
taught a workshop and tried to get
students interested in using community
health maps for their capstone project
so we had six students that ended up
doing that and doing incorporating
community health maps into their
capstone and research and two of the
most impressive interesting projects
were done by this woman Amy saying on
the left to is looking at attitudes that
Asian American have and in Seattle
looking at you know whether they felt
like they were a part of a community in
a heavily Asian neighborhoods one that
wasn't Asian dominated and then
Christina Yount CDs on the right did a
study looking at bicycle safety in
Seattle we've also been to Charleston
several times at the and done workshops
at the Medical University of South
Carolina
we've had several the final workshop
there was hugely popular we had eighty
people show up professors and students
alike and we had several projects that
spun out of that workshop and one was
one of the first workshop attendees was
a gentleman who works at one of the
local high schools mentoring students
and he works on a at a high school on
one of the sea islands outside of
Charleston and so I went one afternoon
on their lunch break and showed the
students how to use fulcrum to collect
data in their community and they were
interested in where the food comes from
and where the fresh water comes from and
so they got really excited about it they
picked up on it on their lunch break and
they spent the semester mapping their
their island and thinking about where
food choices come from and one
interesting thing from this is when
these kids started actually getting out
and collecting the data it really caused
them to think about issues that they
might not have thought about otherwise
like where does the water come from and
what are the foods and how far do we
have to go to get fresh vegetables and
things like that so that that community
involvement can be a really powerful
piece John do you want to take this Zika
curriculum slide and talk about that
sure just
just briefly what we developed what or
what actually Medical University of
South Carolina developed at our request
is a map mapping initiative that enabled
or focused on high school students to be
able to map Zika risk in their community
for example identifying where mosquito
hatch might be and and then making that
information available to their families
and communities as a leadership tool so
that was pretty successful and if you're
interested we do have the full
curriculum but we'd be happy to share
with you next ok now we're going to talk
this one here is about the most disaster
specific project that we've done and
we're still engaged with it and that is
the king tides initiative in Miami now
throughout South Florida it's actually
everywhere but they've coined the phrase
king tides to define those tides that
are super high tides that tend to come
in the fall September October and
November and Kurt and I went down in
September for the first set of tides and
we trained community leaders and
residents with the full training program
but with a particular focus on the
fulcrum data collection initiative or
apart and and we then during the high
floods for September mapped the water
depth the salinity ecoli and coliform
bacteria in yard streets and parks in
low-income in a particular low-income
neighborhood that was pretty successful
and the training that we gave on that
was an abbreviated training only about
three hours and after three hours we
still had the community able to go and
use their handheld devices to do the
data collection we went back
just last week for the higher tides that
were in October curtain I needed boots
the first tide the second time we needed
waders and when were walking through
yards and streets and children's parks
in waders because the tides were so high
again collecting that same information
and we demonstrated also how data
collected that kind of data collected
could be combined with extant databases
that could be overlaid such as
transportation routes or land elevation
socio-economic makeup of the community
so that for example you could look at
where children walk to bus stops or walk
to school and what that route is
relative to the depth of the tide or the
bacterial content of the tides during
the title high tides next slide
so our collaborators there were a pretty
eclectic group but came together quite
happily the Unitarian Universalist
justice heart initiative which kind of
coordinated the neighborhood program
along with new Florida majority and the
Quaker earth care witness folks and then
we did one of the trainings at Florida
International University and it was
their wetland ecosystems research lab
and the School of Journalism that had
developed the data collection tool that
we then put into fulcrum and also the
city of Miami which does its own mapping
but uses ESRI and was looking at the
community health maps tool as a way to
be able to increase community engagement
because one point we want to make is
that the all of the data that is
collected during the community health
are using the community health work flow
is as sophisticated and interoperable
with ESRI data so that you can draw
datasets or work with communities that
use ESRI and work collaborative collab
Burghley with them and both can share
data sets with each other
Curt money you take it and share some of
the maps that we did sure so this is
what it looks like these are screenshots
from my iPhone so this is what fulcrum
looks like once get it onto your phone
so there's two parts of this the form is
first developed on the web browser and
then you use the app on the phone and so
you can see the water the data
collection form on the right hand
screenshot here so these are all the
questions about 15 or 20 questions that
we were answering about every water
sampling location including photos and
video and to show you what what it looks
like once you're done this is a map that
I did in the hotel room in QGIS after
that first weekend in Miami collecting
data in September so this is the shore
crest neighborhood and these couple
streets are the ones that really are
experiencing some of the highest tides
and so here the points you're looking at
or where we collected data and they're
colored by the flood depth so we would
measure the depth of the water and so
the darker the point the deeper the
flood depths and these aren't this is
kind of just a raw first map we were
collecting data before high tide during
high tide and after and you're seeing
all the points here so well we'll be
able to take this further as we have
more time after the data collection
effort to look at what was happening in
those three time periods before during
and after the high tide we can also look
at that same data against elevation data
so here we're looking at the same flood
depth points but now against elevation
of the area and you can see that there
are but the green areas are the the
lowest elevation you know to two feet
and under above sea level so these are
really low-lying areas and you can see
you know from this why some of them
flood and you can also see that some of
the it's a mixed neighborhood where
there's some low-income housing and also
so
more expensive homes and some of the
more expensive homes have actually built
up their lot with a foot or two of fill
so they don't get flooded and that
actually pops out in this elevation data
this is looking at the same data but
this time looking instead of flood depth
that's salinity because this is water
coming from Biscayne Bay through the
storm drains and so the water does have
quite a bit of salinity to it and more
more in some places than others and so
here you can see where the more saline
water is is coming out onto the streets
so those are just some examples of
community health maps in action and one
of the things that we do because we
realize that we do can come we can
accomplish a lot in a half day or a full
day training but we're still only there
for a half day or a full day so there's
more that you can do with these tools
and we have time to cover in a typical
workshop so we have some resources that
we offer people one is a blog so it's
community health maps NLM NIH gov and
this is the technology changes really
quickly so here I can cover changes when
new versions come out or cover new tools
when they appear and also people that
have used community health maps can are
often guest bloggers and they will write
a blog about their experiences using
this so you can search the blog for
keywords and find case studies in here
where people have written about that and
it goes back a couple years at this
point so there's quite a few blog
entries to sift through at this point
another resource that we've offered is a
series of lab exercises
so this focuses on the whole data
collection effort and so the lab number
one is using smartphones to collect data
with fulcrum labs two through five take
a deeper dive into the QGIS GIS software
and how to do different things with it
like do basic spatial analysis map
address based data and then make Maps
with cue just and then lab six
goes through how to do upload into card
oh and a data visualization and card oh
and share that with people and one of
the things that we've also talked of
this lab series are videos so people can
watch a three or four-minute youtube
video instead of reading you know a ten
page lab and so a lot of people prefer
to do that and these are all closed
captioned 508 C compliant so those are
some of the resources we offer and I
think that pretty much is a nice broad
overview of community health maps so I
think at this point we can I'm not sure
what the agenda was we can open it up
for questions yeah thank you so much
that was so interesting I want to make
sure people know at the top of your
WebEx there's a blue box that says chat
and if you click on that that's how you
can get into the chat box there's been a
lot of information that we've pushed out
during this conversation so make sure
that you push out eat that you push on
that button if you haven't yet to see
the links that we've shared and enter
questions and I actually had a couple of
questions so I'll start and my first
question is can with the with the
exercises in the videos that you just
talked about can I teach myself how to
use the tools that you have on the
community health blog or do I need to
take a workshop how would I do that I
think it kind of depends on how much of
a self-starter maybe you might be and
how in you know some people there's
different learning styles but that's the
idea is that I think a lot of people
could take the six labs and they're
probably 30 minutes to an hour each and
you know and spend that time and and
learn how to do this on their own
without a workshop I think it's you know
always better to probably have a
face-to-face interaction initially but I
think a lot of people will be able to
just use the labs to learn how to do
some of this work and I wanted we are in
it we are in the middle now are just in
the actually there
beginning process of developing a
training webinar type program through
NLM so within the next I don't know six
months or a year I'm not sure how long
that's going to take there will be more
of an interactive capability available
that's great to know thank you if I
wanted a workshop how would I do that
why would I get that from you I find out
that the funding for the initiative
comes from NLM and so we have had and
NLM has been very generous over the
years helping develop this and and train
what we tended to do recently is a model
of with the the modest funds that we
have is used that for to get us to the
training and we're looking at
opportunities to Train trainers so for
example we've been to several schools of
Public Health where we're training
students and faculty we're looking at
training institutional memory so that
they so were not training one-off kinds
of things so I suppose one of the things
that could be done is if you're
interested let us know we can't
accommodate everyone who's interested
and we can't even accommodate everyone
who's interested who meets all the
criteria in that that that we might have
but we're we're happy to listen to what
your interests are and perhaps suggest
ways of of going forward with training
that's great thank you somebody has
asked that you put your contact
information in the department I actually
just put gave you back the controls
maybe I did that's actually the chat box
but okay I'll just put them in the chat
box for you and then
I'll ask one more question and then I'll
let Jen take over the question part and
that was how did you decide what
questions to ask in that type project
where you you were showing how you had
your list of questions that you then
gathered the data so how did you
determine those questions except that
was done by the in cooperation with the
the city of Miami and Florida
International University what Kurt did
really was help them organize it into a
fulcrum forum but the kinds of questions
that they were asking in this case it
was water depth
it was salinity it was bacteria
collecting bacteria samples it was the
location it was the name of the data
collector and then we had photo what we
didn't have enough time to show you the
whole thing but you can you can add
photos or video or audio or a number of
things to that fulcrum form so in each
case when we took a water depth we took
a photograph of the yardstick in the
water verifying that that was the depth
when we took the salinity reading from
the water that we took then we we took a
photograph of the of the refractometer
that had the saline content but that was
all done and chosen by the particularly
Port international University but I'll
make a particular point where I think
the valuable of particular value of
fulcrum is is that it's easy it's a
drag-and-drop way to develop the tool so
again going to the importance that we
feel of working with the community or
empowering the community you can sit
together with community members and ask
the kind of questions ask the community
what are the kinds of questions that
they want answers for and then
collaboratively develop that set of
questions whatever your your mission is
or your particular project is
great thank you purity that I could
field that's always an issue so the it's
interesting fulcrum itself is secure
enough for has the same kind of security
that your online banking has which is
great for online banking but apparently
it's not secure enough for HIPAA and the
Privacy Act
so fulcrum is actually aware of that now
and is I think the the squeaky wheel
will get the grease if more people
involved in public health data become
vocal about that but I'm sure they will
work on that security QGIS itself is
just a desktop piece of software so it's
as secure as your system is it's all the
data would be local on your machine so
that security for that doesn't really
come into play and since it's not online
and then Cardo is another online tool
and it the when you upload a data set
into card oh it depends on your
licensing level I believe the free
account does not allow you to lock down
a data set and make it private I think
it's public by default but with a higher
subscription level I think even 25 bucks
a month you can get to the point where
you can make data sets private and then
they are not visible to other users okay
Jen did you see any other questions that
might have been missed I think we've
answered everything you've got the links
to the YouTube and also to the lands
which were the end of things that people
wanted right in all of those I found on
the community health maps blog so that's
the that's really the most important
thing to remember from today is that
community health Maps URL and also this
will be the recording in the slides will
be
add it to our website so and if you're
on our listserv if you're if you're a
member of our listserv we'll send out
the information when we've got them
posted it usually takes a week or so
because we have to make them 508
compliant the recording so it does take
a little bit of time to do that
I saw a related question about security
about Cardo and whether it was HHS
approved and I I don't know specifically
but I would doubt that it is I think it
could get to that point but I probably I
imagine that it just hasn't been used in
that way enough for them to feel the
need to develop that kind of security
oh and I saw a question how to get on
the lift sir if you go to the blog and
the blog is the URL for the blog is on
the slides sign up there
oh so John are you you also have an
email for the blog so when you have an
update you can subscribe to the blog and
get an update correct yeah okay great
so yeah so I put in the information on
how to join the listserv for for
disaster information management Research
Center and we'll send out the
information about when when the
recording and the slides are on our
website but you can also then go to this
to the blog and get updates I can see it
right there on the homepage there's just
a box where you enter your email address
and you can get an update every time a
new blog post is made right and the
resources link on the blog page is where
the lab labs can be found great well I
think I don't see any more questions
you've covered a lot of information for
us I'm I'm looking forward to when the
when the training when you have the
training and six to ten months that's in
an interactive form but meanwhile you do
have these other wonderful resources and
tools and I hope that if anybody uses
these in you know the next six months
that you let us know get get in touch
with us on the listserv or with Kurt and
John and let us know if you use these
tools it's a really valuable resource
that you shared with us oh and one more
thing
the Kurt earlier comment someone asked
about or you asked about what it could
be learned by taking the lab now one of
the things that that if any of the
participants institutions
are familiar with GIS and use it but
don't use the approach that we've
suggested here it may be much easier
learning curve to learn how to use these
tools to complement what they already do
so I would suggest getting in touch
particularly with Kurt you're more
interested in that
John this is Stacey from NLM question
about are you doing so they're they're
often in disasters everybody Under the
Sun wants to do some mapping and they
have mapathon
and hackathons have you brought
community health maps to any of those
types of groups or do you think it could
be used in in that way I know sometimes
the the more expensive programs offer
some free mapping tools for a period of
time in a disaster but that doesn't
really help for the long term so I just
wondered if you had thought about that
in any way
yes thought about it with the time and
resource that we have one of the
challenges that there are so many pop-up
NGOs or groups that have good ideas that
are trying to get attention to them it's
kind of a rat race to get anyone to
really pay attention to a new approach
and we just haven't had the time to do
that what we've hoped is that by getting
some of these pilot programs under our
belt the value of the approach
particularly for example would with the
Zika curriculum that that would get some
attention and that in that way just by
going ahead and doing our work we get
recognition rather than than in taking
the time and expending the energy to try
to promote ourselves in an area that
that's overly active that's kind of
I'm not sure that's a helpful answer but
really to me makes perfect sense to me
thanks Jeff
and Siobhan I was going to attack on to
what you said if anyone does end up
using these tools for a project I want
to put out an invitation to consider
being a guest blogger just a 500-600
word blog with some images of what
you've done would be fantastic we're
always looking for people who have used
this to share their experience with
others so oh great
thank you all right Wow
well jen has been so wonderfully putting
in information about our November call
and where these recordings will be
posted and we've already got somebody
who joined our listserv so we're very
excited about that and thank you John
Thank You Kurt it's been so informative
and really appreciate it and we'll see
you all Thanks thanks so much thank you
so long Thanks